Let's take a look at our Jersey Square team
and because they understand their archetype
is interested in both subscription and rental,
let's see what they were thinking.
And they said well, let's see one
particular model could be an annual subscription,
which is a strategy and here is the tactic
at a $199 per year and we could give them
authentic top of line jerseys and free shipping
and send a jersey back and exchange for another.
We could offer them either a yearly price
or we could offer a monthly price which
would cost more but wouldn't commit them
for such a longer period of time
but they would get the exact same features.
They discovered there was another archetype,
another customer segment that was casual users.
And these people just wanted a one-time
use for a one-week rental for a particular game.
Well you get a top of line jersey and you get
shipping but the goal was you send the jersey
back within one week and we won't charge you
for the jersey and that's a rental.
So they had three pricing models, they were
now going to a/b test for price elasticity.